Problem number 1.
It gives a series--
2, 6, 14, 30.
And they say in the sequence
above the first term is 2.
Each number after the first if
obtained by adding 1 to the
preceding number and then
doubling the result.
So you add 1, so you
get 3, and then you
double it you get 6.
You add 1 to 6 to 7, right, this
is plus 1 and then you
multiply it by 2.
You get 7 times 2 is 14.
14 plus 1 is 15 times 2 is 30.
And they want the sixth term.
So then 30 plus 1 is 31 times
2 is 62 and then you add 1.
We add 1 first. So
you get to 63.
And then you multiply
that times 2.
That's what, 126.
So that is choice E.
Problem 2.
If a times x plus y is equal to
45, and ax is equal to 15,
what is ay equal?
So let's just distribute
this a here.
You get ax plus ay
is equal to 45.
They tell us ax is
equal to 15.
So that is equal to 15--
ax is equal to 15.
So you get 15 plus ay
is equal to 45.
Subtract 15 from both sides and
you get ay is equal to 30.
That's our answer.
They want to know what ay is.
You don't have to solve for
a or y, just ay, so
that's choice E.
Next problem.
Before drawing this let me read
it so I can figure out
what I have to draw.
On the speedometer above what is
the speed in miles per hour
indicated by the needle
position?
So let me see if I
can draw this.
So they give the bottom one
like that, that's given in
feet per second.
And then the next one
up is this one,
that's miles per hour.
And then the top one is
kilometers per hour.
I'm going to write it on this
side, although they write it
up here-- kilometers per hour.
And then they indicate-- and on
the miles per hour thing--
I don't know what you actually
call this measurement.
So there's 30 and then there's
one slash, two slash, three
slash, and then they go to 60.
And then the line that they
draw is right here.
It goes like that.
And they say in the speedometer
above what is the
speed in miles per
hour indicated
by the needle position.
And the reason why I didn't do
much detail on this line or on
this line is because this one's
kilometers per hour and
this is feet per second.
So I don't care about those, I
just care about the miles per
hour, and that is this one.
And let's see, they
drew it here.
So how big is each
of these slashes?
1, 2, 3, 4.
So each of these go 1/4 of the
distance between 30 and 60.
Each of them goes 1/4
of the distance.
So you could say, for example,
this is halfway between 30 and
60, so this is going to be 45.
And so what's halfway between
30 and 45, which is
where the thing is?
Well 45 is 15 more than 30, so
this is going to be 7 and 1/2
more than 30.
So this point right here
is going to be 37.5.
And how do I know that?
If you just say, well if I just
take 30 divided by 4-- 1,
2, 3, 4-- each of these are
going to be 7.5-- right, 30
divided by 4 is equal to 7.5.
Or you could say well this
middle one's definitely going
to be 45 because 45 is right
in between 30 and 60.
And then what's right in
between 30 and 45?
Well that's 37.5 again.
So the speedometer's indicating
37.5 miles per
hour, that's choice B.
Next problem, problem 4.
How many different positive
three-digit integers can be
formed if the three digits, 4,
5 and 6, must be used in each
of the integers.
So they're essentially saying
how many combinations can you
get of the number 456?
So I could write out all those
combinations if you like.
I mean you could 456, 465--
right, those are all of the
ones that if you have
4 in front.
Then if you have 5 in front,
you have 546 or
you can have 564.
I just switched them.
And if you have 6 in front you
could have 645 or 654.
So those are 6.
The other way I think
about it is I have
three numbers, right?
I can put one of three in
the first position.
I can put one of two in
the second position.
And then I would have one left
over in the last position.
I'd have three choices
to put in the first
number, 4, 5 or 6.
Then after I put one in that
first position I have two
left, so there's two more
possibilities, and then I have
one left over for the
third position.
So you could also think
of it this way.
You could just write
them out-- 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6 numbers.
Or you could use that latter
technique I just talked about
and it would be 3 times
2 times 1, which is
also equal to 6.
Next problem.
Let me draw what they
have drawn.
Well I'll try my best. This
line goes like this.
And then there's
a dotted line.
Let me just see if
I can do that.
The hard part of these problems
is drawing them.
Good thing you don't have
to do that on the SAT.
The three-dimensional figure
represented above consists of
rectangular and triangle
faces.
Fair enough, triangular faces.
Each rectangular face
has area r.
So this is a rectangular face
here, there's three
rectangular faces.
So area of the rectangle
is equal to r.
And each triangular
face is area t.
So area of each of the triangle
is equal to t.
What is a total surface
area of the figure in
terms of r and t?
So how many rectangular
surfaces are there?
Well there's this one in back.
It's kind of behind the thing.
You have this base that
I'll drawn in magenta.
This is the base rectangular
surface.
And then you have this one
that's closest to us, which I
could-- this one-- that's the
closest. So you have three
rectangular surfaces.
So it's 3 times r, because each
rectangular surface has
an area or r.
And then how many of
the triangular
surfaces do you have?
You have the one in the back,
back here, and then you have
the one of the front
right here.
So you have two triangular
surfaces.
So it's 3 times the rectangular
areas plus 2 times
the triangular areas because
there's two triangular areas.
So 3r plus 2t, and
that's choice B.
Next problem.
Problem 6.
If n is a positive integer and
n plus 1 over 2 to the n is
equal to 1/2, n equals what?
So let's think about
how we can do this.
Let's multiply both sides of
this equation by 2 to the n.
So if you multiply both sides of
the equation times 2 to the
n, you get n plus 1 is equal
to 1/2 times 2 to the n.
Let me think about this
a little bit.
Let's see, 1/2 times
2 to the n.
1/2 is the same thing as
2 to the negative 1.
So this is n plus 1 is equal
to-- let me think about this.
n plus 1 is equal to 2 to the
negative 1 times 2 to the n.
So n plus 1 is equal
to 2-- sorry.
2 to the n minus 1.
Huh.
So that's where I can get it.
Really at this point, the best
thing I can think of is just
trying out the choices and
see which one works.
If you look at choice A, 1--
actually, we could just do it
from the original,
that's faster.
1 plus 1 over 2 to the n is
equal to 2 over 2 to the 1,
which is equal to 1.
So it's not 1/2, so it's
not a equals 1.
Choice B is 2.
So it would be 2 plus 1, which
is 3 over 2 squared, which
equals 3/4.
So that's not the answer.
If you look at choice
C, choice C is 3.
So 3 plus 1 is 4 over
2 to the third.
That's 4 over 8 equals 1/2.
So it's choice C.
And I'm trying to figure out
if there's a way that you
could solve for that easier
other than trying out the
numbers, but for some reason
it's not popping into my head.
Let me know a message if
you figure it out.
But I also do these under
time pressure.
But I will see you in
the next video.